yes, well, the idea or strategy
in general is
to build up such a complementary portfolio, that also means to
map all stages of Angel where I
am relatively involved relatively
early phase to make a little later
stage topics and also to
map PI then it will also be about that
somehow go to cover geographies and
industries, but in the end it's also a lot
about relationships for me and they
usually invest
serious a and later and because I
have a relatively early-stage strategy, for me the funds in particular are
somehow much more exciting
because of that  many people also went to get to know
the ecosystem in the network exchange
and
to build up this portfolio in the segment